Film Courage: How do we know if the plot progression
in a screenplay makes sense?
Naomi Beaty, Writer, Screenwriting Teacher
and Consultant: I think that it’s just common
sense.
You’re going to sort of follow the logic
of your story.
Is that what you mean?
Film Courage: Yes…well…maybe a better
question is what if the plot progression is
taking too long?
Maybe that’s a better question.
My question is taking too long!
Sorry.
Naomi: No…that’s a good question.
So I think that that is subjective right?
And it depends on what you’re going for,
it depends on the story you are telling, the
pace that you sort of expect from the story
in that genre and that style.
There is no black and white answer but I do
think when you’re reading a script right
one of the big red flags is boredom.
So this might be something that you can only
figured out your entire plot and you get fresh
eyes on it you might think that it moves like
a runaway train and then you might have somebody
else look at it and they say “Oh gosh, when
is it going to get going?
When is it going to start?”
I think that the sort of natural approach
is to get your story moving as quickly as
possible and make sure you’re escalating
the conflict and escalating the stakes consistently
throughout the story and building on that
throughout all of act two but if you’ve
done that and broken a story, plotted the
whole thing out, you think it’s great, I
would still say it’s a great way to get
a fresh set of eyes on it so you can see if
everyone else agrees with you and they think
the pace is okay of your story as well.
Film Courage: Right, I guess there is also
pacing that is too fast?
Naomi: Yes and that’s what we’re talking
about letting moments breathe because we want
to sort of see the emotional reactions of
stories to.
We don’t want to see the emotional reactions
of stories too.
We don’t want…I mean sometimes we just
want an action movie that just movies from
action-to-action right?
But more often I think we’re interested
in what is the effect of this plot on this
character.
That’s what we actually care about when
we’re watching a movie or reading a script.
We want to know what is the experience like
for this person going through this?
What are they feeling?
What are they thinking?
How is this causing them to change or re-prioritize
what is in their life?
So I think yes, pace in a script can be too
fast at times if it doesn’t give us those
moments of reaction and sort of processing
emotions so that we understand what’s the
emotional journey of this story as well not
just the plot.
Film Courage: Going back top biopics I think
sometimes where they fall short in is the
pacing is too fast because they are trying
to cram too much and I know we were talking
about the movie SEBERG off camera.
I thought the pacing was great but you’d
have to see it.
Naomi: Biopics are tough because I think a
lot of times people try and make a story of
someone’s entire life or maybe that’s
the instinct of this was such an iconic person.
I want to tell the whole story of their entire
life and very few peoples’ lives are actually
one story.
Most of our lives are episodic so you have
to pick what is the episode from your life
that’s a transformative, defining experience,
and then tell that story.
Don’t tell me the whole thing.
Just give me that transformative experience.
Film Courage: Great point, yes.
I think that’s what it did for the most
part.
It didn’t totally follow her whole journey.